any funny stories from the set that you
could share oh god it was so long ago
i'm sure they're
man
you know there were a bunch of bloopers
and mishaps obviously there's always
that stuff on on set which is funny with
the crew or
you know some of the improv was
hysterical that me and chelsea mourinho
had she played my fiance caitlin
there uh kevin really let us go a few
times there was a dinner scene we were
drinking wine
fake wine and
uh it was kind of sexual there was some
sexual undertones there
and uh
he let me really go which was fun and i
think we did like maybe 13 14 takes
of of but it was it was all different
you know it was great and also the scene
where so ryan he finds drugs
in this church that he's working at he's
supposed to install security cameras in
his church he stumbles upon all this
cocaine
and he's like well
i'm gonna sell this
you know this is the whole this is how
he gets all kind of in trouble with the
the mob
uh and he and he go goes to meet a drug
dealer
now ryan is a regular kind of like not
uppity not not a yuppie type per se but
more of an upscale you know comes from a
good family
uh and
he's not like a thuggish you know he
doesn't associate with drug dealers on a
daily basis
so the scene where i go to meet the drug
dealer to make the drug deal with
chelsea caitlyn my fiance
was
my favorite scene in the film because
it's me and a diner we're meeting this
drug dealer who they picked a great
character his name is c i think in his
in real life his name was c2 um don't
quote me on that but he was like this
big hispanic
tough just
his
like hysterical actor great character
actor and he he was so scary and just
a lot of times i would i would try and
speak to him like you know here we have
the drugs like
so house is going to go down and he just
wouldn't say anything
enemy and i'm sitting there you know
just really scared because this is a v
we're in shady neighborhood
he could pull out a gun at any moment
we're trying to get money out of this
guy who could probably kill us you know
it's me and my beautiful fiance here and
it made for a very very comedic scene
and i think you should
i hopefully it'll
turn out great